Alohomora sorry is trying to unlock a
movie I'm more interested in fantastic
beasts the crimes of Brenda wall new
trailer first trailer I can't I can
barely remember at this point it feels
like we've been building up to this
thing forever but you know what despite
my admittedly sort of deliberately
abrasive intro I didn't hate this
trailer which was surprising cuz there's
a lot I don't that is kind of weighing
against this project for me on a number
of levels first and foremost being I
didn't really like the last one but
beyond that the you know the entire
premise and what it's about is not
really what I want out of Harry Potter
world set films at this point I want to
you know have more time and do all more
in that world and it feels like they're
just retreading you know the the latter
Harry Potter movies by going dark wizard
who we must stop it like but I I mean
you know it worked in those films cuz
they built up to it and they'd earned it
and I I kind of kind of want just
getting to enjoy dwelling in this world
a little bit more say you know like
first four films in the Harry Potter
franchise feel more than the the latter
four but that all being said don't hate
the trailer for one thing it's it's a
lot brighter than the than the last film
was last film was irritatingly gloomy it
was all there was a lot of dark there
was a lot of haze there was a lot of
muted colors and I really didn't like
them um so there's a it feels like
there's a lot more color on display so
that helps I like that we get our first
taste of Jude Law's Dumbledore seems to
be pretty solid casting I like Jude Law
in general he's very charming
so that should work we get a glimpse of
Johnny Depp is Grindelwald yeah whatever
depends on how much they have him talk
he'll probably be fine
being that gave me the biggest grin
though Jacob Jacob and Queenie were the
best parts of the first film like I
wanted the entire film to be about them
so I'm glad he's back I'm assuming queen
he's back as well I'm not excessively
following every little tidbit about the
making in this movie because I it's hard
for me to get invested because I'm a lot
of Me's assuming that I won't like it
but I do enjoy a lot of the imagery that
we've got on this because honestly a lot
of the imagery is what I said I wanted
you know it's more the first four movies
in the Harry Potter franchise it's that
sense of Wonders like there's people
floating in bubbles not sure why but
kind of a neat look and there's you know
we get a few looks at locations and a
few other things like that that have
that sense of wonder to them however I
also know what the films about so I'm
not counting on this maintaining that
throughout if it can tap into it at all
it'll be a positive it'll be something
in the films favor and they've certainly
spot-checked those moments for the
trailer which at least as far as a fan
like me goes was a smart thing to do so
well played marketing team it I mean I
need the fine I would I will have to
actually see the film and get full sort
of context for this but for what I saw
of Newt Scamander it seems odd that he
would be like Dumbledore's hand-picked
msre
or agent or anything I mean that you
know nice guy and all that you know
means well but he wouldn't be my first
pick so that I'd be curious to see how
they justify his presence for like for
lack of a better term narrative Lee I
mean you know if for as long as they're
gonna call the franchise fantastic
beasts I'm sure he'll still be around
but like how do you justify a creature
enthusiast be involved in battling
wizard Hitler I don't know he kind of
had to do
defy it somehow and it also looks like
we're not totally ditching the beasts
either we get a glimpse of a few and we
got a funky bird kind of thing we got a
little honestly looks like a little
green version of groups running around
who knows what it is I want more of that
I want more of that stuff
I don't know how much of it they'll be
but it's in the trailer so again that's
a good thing pretty sure I'd spotted
Ezra Miller which annoyed me I forgot
that they brought him back I don't know
why he wasn't interesting or compelling
or really anything other than a really
bad haircut but other than that it's
just a lot of glimpses of settings and
characters and it's a first teaser so
we're not getting a lot of plot beyond
what the title basically tells us and
sort of the just what we know based off
the trajectory of the franchise and
what's been said by the people making it
up to this point but like I said
considering I I think ultimately I have
to call this a pretty good teaser
because as someone who's coming at this
with a deficit of interest and and you
know every reason to just dismiss this
out of hand the fact that the trailer
made me go okay that's not too bad for
someone who's coming in with a more
neutral or positive inclination you
probably love this trailer you might
even love the movie heck I might even
love the movie that'd be a pleasant
surprise
again I didn't like the first one very
much but now it's a pretty decent teaser
and while it doesn't suddenly make me
hopeful for the film it is at least
showing me that the stuff I want to see
is in there somewhere it's now a
question of is it there in a token
fashion or is it actually what the film
is and I suspect it's the former if it's
the latter that'd be awesome but that's
sort of my thoughts overall not too bad
which considering how down I am on
project for a number of reasons which I
suppose it's worth retouching on one of
those again it it was irritating seeing
Dumbledore say you have to confront
Grindelwald because I cannot and knowing
that the film because it's been made
clear the film is not going to address
the past relationship between
Grindelwald and Dumbledore and not that
this is necessarily the reason that
they're not gonna do it but doing so
would involve finally saying canonically
in the narrative that Dumbledore is gay
and we know they're not going to do that
in this film and it's it was it did
earth me to see that because the perfect
explanation for why he can't do it it
has to be Newt is my feelings obscure my
judgment I can't be faced with him but
we know they're not going to address
that properly and I've got a whole other
video talking about that so I'm not
gonna rehash all that from scratch here
but that I I it was that was a sin I was
really trying to ignore for the two
minutes or whatever that this teaser
went on but I feel like it kind of
brought it up itself and it made me a
little irritated but other than that you
know pretty decent trailer how I expect
I'll see this movie regardless we'll see
what happens
so teaser for fantastic beasts the
crimes of bring the walled indefinite
contention for worse title of any movie
coming out this year hey did you see it
what are your thoughts on it whatever
they are drop things down in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
the stuff to do you know the likes and
subscribes in patreon support and buy
t-shirt follow me on Twitter etc etc etc
at least for all that stuff is down
below until next time NOx
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]